le milliardaire américain est le musk a
lancé cette semaine un concours ils
offrent 100 millions de dollars pour
développer de nouvelles technologies
pour retirer du co2 de l'atmosphère
de quoi relancer l'intérêt envers un
projet canadien qui enfouit le co2 à des
kilomètres sous terre
[Musique]
que ce soit pour fabriquer ciment et
jouets ou d'électricité
l'humanité produits toujours plus de co2
mais au lieu de le racheter dans l'air
certains cherchent à l'enfouir sous
terre
[Musique]
la saskatchewan a bien besoin de virage
vers la quasi-totalité son électricité
provient de centrales qui carbure gaz ou
pire au charbon on peut rendre le
charbon plus vers huy la saskatchewan
c'est très plat ça limite nos options
pour l'hydroélectricité l'énergie
solaire n'est pas toujours au rendez
vous
l'éolien non plus alors comme énergie de
base le charbon a encore sa place si on
fait bien les choses
la centrale thermique bande breedam est
la plus grande la province
on y brûle chaque année quatre millions
de tonnes de charbon provient des mines
de la région
mais une des cheminées le crash presque
rien
les émanations d'une des turbines
alimentées au charbon sont captés par l'
usine à ma droite le groupe de lusine
sert à récupérer le soufre et les
particules fines
ce qui fait qu'il y a très peu
d'émissions on capte environ 95% des gaz
à effet de serre produit par la
combustion du charbon le co2 capté est
ensuite comprimé et l'équipe d'éric
nicole en reçoit une partie pour le
projet expérimental à christophe
[Applaudissements]
l'objectif d'en fuir le co2 à plus de 3
km de profondeur
parce qu'on y retrouve réservoir naturel
doté de son propre couverte c'est ce qui
nous sert de couvercles une épaisse
couche de cette roche qui est très dense
très peu perméables et nous on injecte
le co2 dans la couche degré qui est en
dessous on la compare souvent à une
éponge qui y seraient fait de grains de
sable quand on injecte le co2 ils se
logent d'abord dans les ports de la
roche
puis ils se mélangent à l'eau salée qui
est déjà là éventuellement il va réagir
avec laroche et se solidifier on parle
de centaines de milliers d'années
et aujourd'hui une caméra pour descendre
jusque dans ce réservoir
en plongeant dans le co2 qui transparent
elles vont inspecter et 3200 mètres de
tuyaux pour vérifier si la plomberie
tient le coup après cinq ans d'injection
c'est assez excitant je passe mes
journées à imaginer ce qui se déroule là
dessous mais le voir c'est vraiment rare
les résultats sont positifs il y a très
peu de corrosion et les quelques
cristaux de sel ne risque pas de boucher
les trous par lesquels on injecte mais
pour ce qui est de voir où s'envolent
co2 il faut s'y prendre autrement
[Musique]
on semblait profondeur à coups de
dynamite la première étape c'est
d'enfouir des micros un peu partout sur
le site
quand on crée une détonation les ondes
se propage dans le sol et rebondi sur le
co2 pour profondeur
elles sont ensuite capté par les micros
et analysés pour en faire une image un
peu comme une échographie
l'équipe a mené l'opération cinq fois
avant l'injection de co2 ensuite à
trente six mille tonnes injecté puis à
100 2141 1000 et 2 172 milles tonnes de
co2 et ça continue
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant on enfourne 310 mille
tonnes de co2 c'est l'équivalent de 75
mille voitures qu'on retirait de la
route pendant un an et ça on en est très
fier
c'est notre raison d'être au fond
j'adore ce genre de projet ou la science
permet de faire avancer les choses au
point
[Musique]
bien entendu il faut que le co2 reste
dans son réservoir pour s'en assurer
l'équipe récolte des échantillons d'eau
et étudie les échanges gazeux avec le
solde pour l'instant aucun signe qu'une
co2 remontent à la surface
[Musique]
il faudrait retranchements il y a
plusieurs coachs étanche semblable à
celle qui sert de couvercle au réservoir
et la roche ou en injecte est beaucoup
plus profonde que les autres zones
poreuses où on puisse du pétrole une des
raisons d'avoir choisi cette strate
c'est que les pétrolières ne viennent
pas et forêts et les mines de potasse
elles sont plus au nord on est les seuls
à utiliser cette couche de roches
poreuses
[Musique]
à mesure que les roches digère le co2 un
réseau de 600 micro écoute en permanence
les gargouillis qui proviennent des
entrailles de la terre à l'affût par
exemple de micro séismes
et satellite observe aussi la position
de ces bornes pour voir si les
changements de pression font des formes
et le sol ne serait ce que d'un
millimètre
l'équipe vérifie aussi que le sol est
pas en train de saturer mais c'est tout
le contraire
son appétit et presque sans limite la
capacité des normes du moins en théorie
la formation rocheuse qui nous sert de
réservoir couvre tous ceux des prairies
et s'étend aux états unis on pourrait y
injecter des milliards de tonnes de co2
la priorité daqui store c'est justement
d'aider d'autres projets à se développer
l'équipe a testé toute une panoplie
d'outils de surveillance pour savoir
lesquels sont vraiment nécessaires
c'est vraiment le grave la voir le
minimum d'outils de suivi pour réduire
les coûts tout en maintenant la
confiance du public et des décideurs et
surtout pour bien comprendre et montrer
qu on comprend ce qui se passe en
profondeur
[Musique]
la capture et le stockage du co2 ont
évidemment un prix et pour certaines
mieux vaudrait se débarrasser du charbon
que d'essayer de le rendre moins
polluants mais le projet va bien au delà
christophe s'est associé à une centrale
au charbon oui mais c'est une
technologie qui peut améliorer le bilan
environnemental d'autres industries
aussi les usines de ciment les
raffineries les centrales au gaz ou la
production d'engrais émettent beaucoup
de co2 et les émissions sont concentrés
à un endroit alors on pourrait les
capter les enfouir
après tout peu importe ce qu'ils
aimaient le co2 son origine est toujours
la même
des énergies fossiles extraites du sol
alors autant retourner ce co2 là d'où il
vient
[Musique]